ah who could it be  should I know you know  but a mother never forgets you know my  cousin sad boy think you got the wrong  guy homes everyone saying that body or  sleepy he'd like to Mexican Wolverine  and my partner here you want to see that  product when he talking my name yeah  seriously you like apple I do like Apple  but don't make me I don't want to have  to choose between you night Larry Larry  she's telling me to take you out I'm a  veteran that's amazing yeah frickin  immature idea cuz I don't care I'm old  I've already look long enough you have a  really bad habit having these  conversations the wrong time I want to  come clean to you want me to make a mess  sir can I talk to you for a second  please news news meet with me it was me  I'm sorry I'm literally gonna kill you  I do not one war do not come back